for all my friends who are over 30 and
start peeing more at night I have solved
this so I tried all sorts that was like
put your water at the beginning of the
day put your water at the end of the day
like eat salt tabs at night so you
increase your ADH levels like I've tried
everything the thing that actually
solved it for me and you're going to
lose your mind when you hear it is that
I stopped drinking so much water because
the thing is is you got all these Health
gurus who are like drink so much water
drink so much water drink so much water
and you know what ended up happening I
pee all the time ancient man probably
didn't have a gallon of water every day
we probably did was he drank when he was
thirsty and so I stopped planting any
kind of water or liquid consumption I
only drink until I'm not thirsty anymore
and I don't drink extra and so simply
removing that got rid of all of my
nighttime peeing I think for me I'd
rather be a little bit dehydrated than
not get a good night's sleep and I'd
pick that any night of the week